a grassroots effort begins to grow a las
vegas man
seeks help from the community to collect
school supplies for students in need
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how he's giving back
and the inspiration behind it working
really hard as a team as a school to
figure everything
out daniela silverstein adjusts to a new
normal teaching online is a whole new
thing
bringing challenges for the kindergarten
teacher at john s park elementary school
things that we totally don't think about
are new things that we think about
that includes school supplies for her
students at home during distance
education
students are doing specials online so pe
art music all that stuff they don't have
paint they don't have paint brushes
jump ropes bean bags just anything to
participate really
but her friend brandon johnson wants to
help silverstein says he responded to
her social media post
about the issues last week and is taking
the initiative to aid
educators they gave me the opportunity
to help kids
pencils colors he's starting a donation
drive no name
just a mission help the kids some of
these parents can't afford it he's
partnering with businesses and churches
around the valley to take
these large gray bins we want to make it
as easy as possible for people to donate
so i ultimately went 50 drop spots
across the city to keep it coveted safe
all bins will be outside businesses
where anyone who wants to donate can
drop off supplies
and then walk away i will be personally
driving by each bin
to check each bin and collect them all
supplies going to park elementary and
miley achievement center elementary
school for students to pick
up and grab bags this effort though may
include more soon
ultimately i want to help anybody who
reaches out to me any teacher at any
school
giving students a chance to succeed this
year
kristen drummond 8 news now a wish list
is also online for people not
comfortable leaving their homes because
of covid19
for that list and bin locations as well
as drop off times just visit our website
8newsnow.com